how are you Mike first of all the
maintainer is a sequel to they equal us
is that right where I go around I go
around and for people who have trouble
maintaining I help them maintain you
don't you don't hurt anyone you just
maintain that well no I do it alive
opportunity equal you're the opposite
you keep people alive because you
maintain that but like that is better
you know what so without the vigilantism
is what you're saying without the
vigilante stop well that is a great
nickname that could have been a my
fantasy team the main thing I mean tell
me by the way I'll be your avatar
I'll be your avatar certainly since
we're in the Bleacher Report family now
all together Mike can you've been with
bleach reports since 2013 when people
were probably wondering what you were up
to doing that sorry it has been really
an amazing ride and I'll just make this
brief when bleachers started it was a
very unique idea but a lot of people
didn't know what to make of it and then
it took this dramatic turn towards a lot
more journalism a lot more of everything
and now it's you know I I've worked at
the New York Times or Washington Post
Boston Globe Dallas Morning News I've
worked a lot of really good places it's
one of the best places I've ever worked
and because they really focus on stuff
that I like like really good journalism
really good writing it's been a
remarkable ride and transformation and I
feel like this is just not to get all
sappy I'm gonna start crying but you
have been one of my favorite guys you a
lot of people in our biz in my business
become on your show just really like you
because you're just a really good honest
dude I think I'm gonna are you telling
me to live long and prosper Mike are you
telling me to live long and prosper
prosper right now the other reason I
love come on your show okay so let's get
by the way thank you and again we here
are thrilled to be part of the Bleacher
family and be our live
and look forward to how we can all work
together so are they gonna make any
changes to the instant replay system do
you think to make sure what happened in
the NFC Championship game never happens
again do you think that will actually
happen over the next 24 hours Mike we're
still we're still waiting to see rates
one thing you know is I know there's
been some reporting on this and I've
heard the exact same thing that Sean
Payton as you would guess just one of my
favorite guys in the league by the way
just a really good smart coach who
Saints got royally screwed last year in
the playoffs so obviously some Payton is
still upset about that understandably
and he's been really passionate and
vocal behind the scenes about trying to
get some changes done with that there's
there's always you know this you've been
around the league a long time
there's always resistance initially to
certain changes to really to change in
general from a league that moves at
times that are very glacial pace when it
comes to changing on many different
levels and some of that is happening now
I think there's just owners that are
sort of a little bit nervous about doing
anything drastic but having said that I
think there's a lot of support behind I
don't know if it's going to be any
changes are going to pass or not but I
think there's owners who realize that
you need to sort of modernize the game
and make the game advance as people's
viewing habits as we can see very easily
now if you watch the game on TV what the
proper call is now most people are so
educated and a lot of the calls you can
see what's going on so you have to
account for that exact like it doesn't
exist I know and I know and then that's
part of the issue here where we're one
of the more influential owners in John
Mara is says you know we shouldn't take
the onside kick and turn it into a
fourth and 15 play form either the 25 or
the 35 because they're not the Arena
League to me that's out of touch and
then you've got coaches who vote
unanimously apparently at their meeting
30 to nothing to let some official
that's already sitting up stead
make a ruling on a play that needs to be
reviewed sort of like a sky judge like
the AF has which I don't like because I
don't see a challenge flag I'm sitting
at home and then all of a sudden I think
a play that doesn't get challenged is
being challenged by somebody that buzzes
in from some you know from underneath
you know
Zed's chopper shop you know what I mean
like that's the same like we don't know
we don't see where this person's coming
from let's just let the coaches I know
they've got enough on their hands but
let them use a challenge flag keep the
challenge universe the same just to get
right get you the third you don't expand
that and that you if you do give them a
challenge for something that's a
judgment call and they get it wrong then
penalize them yards on top of losing the
challenge and boom you make the last two
minutes some sort of rule where it has
to be a blatant call to have somebody
buzz in from New York City and then we
have an argument what blatant is but we
all know what blatant looks like sort of
like the the famed phrase about what
pornography is for the lack of a better
phrase I think we can all work this out
Mike I think you just did but the the
problem the problem is the league and
and they one of the interesting parts of
this as coaches used to always be the
ones that were that wanted to move very
slowly because they were more affected
directly they had to manage all these
changes that owners and gyms were put in
place and coaches always wanted to move
a little bit slower now I feel like the
coaches are sort of leading the charge
some of it is some of it is
self-centered of course because if you
lose a game the way the Saints did that
is brutal but I think I also think it's
which would stone pavement some these
other coaches are doing is smart it's
really just sort of saying let's just
keep moving forward into the modern and
there's a 21st century keep the game
interesting keep it moving forward and
you know what tell rich I would say what
the owners are thinking in some ways is
look at how popular the game is
look at it I mean have we lost some
viewers we have but look at the numbers
we're getting look at how many people
watch and I don't want to screw that I
want to keep that going the way it is
and that's not an unfair argument but
eventually that stuff catches up to you
and eventually do have to adapt and keep
and keep just saying this is the 21st
century let's change some things up not
gonna kill us it'll probably make the
game more exciting and it won't look
like the Arena League it'll look like
the NFL football that we love because
they have NFL caliber athletes who make
the game look as powerful as fun and and
as graceful as it is it a couple of
minutes left with our bleacher report
compadre Mike Freeman alright walk me
through the way Arizona is either gonna
make a decision on calamari or if you
think they've already made one the
decision they make with Josh Rosen Mike
I think this is a really compelling
problem for them everything I hear is
they're they're taking Murray I mean
we're we're still a little ways out rich
and things change on a dime in
everything in his league that's in the
draft but they really like him and I
gotta say I there's not much to not like
I mean he's five foot ten so what I mean
the way the game is played now that
doesn't matter he's really smart people
who know him and know his family really
really speak incredibly highly of him I
think Arizona sees all this and thinks
we need we need to get this guy I don't
think they're convinced this regime this
coaching staff that Rosen is their guy
and I think they're they're more than
willing to go with that number one pick
with Murray that's way that's way it
seems now as you know the stuff changes
crazily rapidly but Murray has impressed
almost everyone in the league that who
has come in contact with with him who's
worked him out who's really in position
that they love him so I don't see how
the card was going
of the ways but crazy things happen in
the if they do that then they have to
draft him and then make an announcement
that they've traded rosin on the spot to
to exact the draft choices in that very
same draft right they've got to have
something than their top right-hand
drawer to pull out the minute that they
Valerie's name to the commissioner yeah
I think I think when when they do that I
think Josh Rosen will be playing
somewhere else and there will be takers
there's people who like him they think
he's got a good future so if it will
there will be ways to what make this
work out and some teams will be very
interested and who knows it could happen
before that but probably is something
like very quickly you you draft more you
trade rosin and then you're good to go
and I think that's the way that I think
that's the way they what they should do
only because I think Murray has a much
much brighter future especially the way
the game was played now his his mobility
I'm not saying he's like Mike Vick I'm
not saying he's fast but he's very
capable of just moving around in the
pocket he's great at this the way the
NFL is changing the way the NFL's played
now wide open not as physical he's
perfect for that he that's what he does
and I think the Cardinals see that Mike
thanks for the call first of many
appreciate you being here on their first
day on PR live from Bleacher Report all
right I need you to do one thing for me
I need you rich live long and prosper I
shall do that like I shall do that I'm
giving you I'm giving you this
maintainer and maintain Oh take care of
Mike that's at Mike Freeman NFL right
here in the show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience